it was like a dream and i was kind of
hesitating to do it because of how my
family and everybody was going to look
at me
i feel great you know you know how they
used to say jesus first and jesus take
the word to him and this you know direct
violence yeah confession box no going
through a priest to forgive your sin
just to the one god
i actually been
been studying for four years
for four years for four years somebody
paid you cursed you four years
investigating i didn't even know what to
expect you know i was in my car for like
20 minutes
i didn't even know like i was shy to
come here you know if allah i want to
guide you here just follow him
we have uh avelson
molina here
from ponciana
the brother here
uh
we got in contact about a couple of
months ago and he's been coming uh
periodically a few times
about islam he's been interested in
islam
quite a while now
and uh matter of fact about a month and
a half two months ago
we were here
throughout the afternoon until uh
evening
until sun
set
and
he was
probably
very
convinced to take the shahada but for
some reason allan was best he was not
certain and we said
take your time you know do some more
research
until you see that you are
fully uh
convinced
and convicted about islam
and then when couple of months went by
and we
we chatted
over phones and uh
finally
yesterday
he calls me and he tells me
you know he's ready to become a muslim i
was very happy
for him because
as
we all know
this moves us greatly whenever we know
someone to come to the fold of islam
because
this is something
that is no greater gift
than allah
rewards some somebody with islam
so
today
inshallah
we decided
to meet
after jummah
tonight
here the masjid in davenport
uh in front of the brothers here
and uh i have here
uh
quite a few brothers here in in our
presence
and uh insha'allah we will
start
with the declaration of faith inshallah
which
states
that is
there is no
god worthy of worship
except
the one true god which is allah
and and i bear witness
that
prophet muhammad
is the
messenger of god
and i bear witness also that jesus
the son of marian
jesus christ is also the messenger of
god
this declaration
is that
you entered the fold of islam
now we're going to start this inshallah
there is no there is no true god true
god except allah except allah i bear
witness bear witness that is that
muhammad muhammad may peace be upon him
he is the messenger of allah the
messenger
and i bear witness i bear witness jesus
christ jesus the son of mary the son of
mary is the messenger of god a messenger
of god
[Music]
now
[Music]
congratulations thank you man how do you
feel you feel great i'm eddie you're 80.
yes sir eddie 80.
pretty close huh yeah yeah so tell me
how was it what was it that just in a
few words what was it that led you to
really contemplating and thinking about
the purpose of life that led you
actually from all the different
religions you chose islam
man to be honest i was a born catholic i
was i was born into a catholic family so
um just growing up i wasn't really
understanding what i was praying to you
know
they was telling me there was three gods
you know i wasn't really sure what i was
doing so you know growing up i was just
doing my research just myself
i had a couple friends who used to take
the village in super serious but you
know i was a catholic so i didn't really
see it like that so
after i got into it after i got into and
stuff you know i just
i just thought that
it was a reason for me to be here you
know because
it was just
it was just out of nowhere
that i was just like you know what
i want i want to practice the islamic
religion i don't know where i just came
here
and
like i said like i was like
it was like a dream literally like a
dream it just came to my head just came
to my head of becoming a muslim you know
and um
you know i'm here and i was kind of
hesitating to do it because of how my
family and everybody was gonna look at
me my family don't even know i'm here
you know and um
i feel great and i and i'll feel like
they'll feel happy for me too for what i
did so your background is from the
dominican republic yes sir there's a lot
of spanish people from
all parts of the latin community spanish
community that we're seeing there's an
influx of hispanics coming to islam for
exactly the same reason you know they
are having a hard time identifying with
the trinity jesus being god part of a
tree but when they come to islam the
pure monotheism it really connects with
their heart the oneness the pure oneness
was that something that really
captivated you yes and i want to be able
to
you know
um
you know um pray pray to my pray to my
god you know pray to my god only not
just
you know you know how they used to say
jesus first and jesus take the word to
him and this you know direct dialogue
yeah i want to i want to be directly
towards him you know pray to him so he
can hear me how i really feel no
confession box no going to a priest to
forgive your sin just to the one god
almighty also directly yes sir because
what i'm concerned is we we always
his kids we owe his uh
you know daughters and sons so why why
wouldn't we be able to pray to him you
know directly to like to him you know
metaphorically yes but we know now you
learn coming to islam that's the
beautiful thing when you for instance
you learn that god doesn't have children
daughters sons he's nothing like his
creation and this is the way of the
natural ways we want to congratulate you
you know for coming thank you uh except
you know this is a beautiful day taking
your shahadah may god
continue to bless you thank you and
we've been welcoming to the community
and uh the community not just here but
close to two billion all over the world
yes sir and i'm super happy to be here
man like i say i actually been
been studying for four years
for four years for four years since i
was like 15 years old
i actually started you know doing some
research on it but like i said yes
but like i said um just never took the
step was kind of afraid of you know
you know like the people around me and
stuff how would it look at me you know i
was young you know so
but thank god i'm here you know i didn't
get lost a lot guided me here
you know so nobody paid you cursed you
four years investigating this using your
mind praying directly to god almighty
yes sir you did your homework and you
concluded that indeed this is the way of
life from the creator that happens in
the earth yes sir and the way the wages
how
you know
the muslim community just you know
maneuver the way they uh they take the
religion so serious and and how they
always try to do uh
like good like good things you know like
they avoid bad things you know i mean
always and um
and i feel like that's great you know
what i mean and
um i mean i can't i can't wait to you
know actually learn everything and one
last thing how did you feel from shaykh
sammy and the rest of the community you
know
the the love you know the ki how did you
feel being accepted into the man since
day one since day one they supported me
since i came here like you can't even
ask them i i was super shy when i first
came here i was in the corner over there
and i didn't even know what to expect
you know i was in my car for like 20
minutes
i didn't even know like i was shy to
come here you know but when i came in
you know they grab me come over here
sit down with us since day one they show
me love man and that's why you guys are
great people all you guys and um
like i said i can't wait i can't wait to
really be
me come here and really uh do what i
have to do and what i've been waiting
for
because you know
it's really a dream coming true to be
honest and i'm glad i was here to
witness that yes all right you guys also
if you'd like to read the book also that
convinced him to had all the evidences
and proofs you can get your free copy of
the quran at thedeenshow.com and if you
have any questions
you want to learn call us at
eight hundred 1-800-662-4752-1800 we'll
see you next time inshallah assalamu
alaikum peace be with you thank you
thank you and one more thing can i say
one more time to the videos okay so
everybody um
just do what your heart tells you don't
let nobody tell you what to do um
if allah want to guide you here just
follow him like it won't be the wrong
like it'll probably be the best the best
decision you guys can make
um don't let people around you tell you
what to do
um and make sure you know um you know
what you're doing
meaning like uh you make the right
decision
on what you're doing
and um just be safe guys thank you all
right thank you for sharing that with us
brothers and sisters this is your
brother eddie from the d show and i have
some amazing news for you we just made a
down payment and are in contract to
purchase this 35 000 square foot
facility with over four acres to make it
the dean center
alhamdulillah the project includes a
masjid an athletic facility a live
studio for recording the d show and tawa
outreach programs and as you've known
i've been looking for a no interest
owner financing and alhamdulillah i
found this church property for 2.5
million that will do all of it i've
given a hundred thousand dollar down
payment to enter into the contract and
one million dollars will be paid over 36
months inshallah with no interest
alhamdulillah but right now we need 1.4
million to close on this property
brothers and sisters help us purchase
this property to build the dean center
donate right now may god almighty allah
reward all of you brothers and sisters
[Music]